do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do do do do
make sure I'm being seen and hurt
I've seen as much as I'm showing at the
moment
ah
let's see here we go
all right
done
dinner
cheers folks
hope everybody's doing well
so yes I had a uh a rather severe trim
um from where it was more around here
and obviously a uh a color refresh
you thought I was going to shave my head
no you didn't
[Laughter]
ah
yeah yeah John I agree I like these
colors together hey everybody good to
see you all here
um hope everybody is doing well oh thank
you Carolyn
uh I forgot to announce the stream
outside of um
outside of
just setting the dang thing up
sometimes I remember this time I did not
Talk Amongst yourselves
the Holy Roman Empire was neither holy
no Roman nor an Empire discuss
[Music]
there we go
uh I was wondering who was going to get
the Linda Richmond reference
hi it's Linda Richmond welcome to Coffee
Talk we talk we smooth no big whoop
uh would I like to see the Ood again in
Doctor Who
I would like to know what story someone
would intend to tell with them because
they're generally the ones that I'm like
we should bring that one back it's not
just like a general I think they're cool
or an aesthetic I I want to know that
there is
more stories to tell it's why I think
Omega is really obvious to bring back
yet they continue to not and
um like why I'd still be on the fact
that Mr Finch
um
uh Anthony Stewart head from uh School
reunion has never come back because
there's a hell of a lot more you could
do with that character
um the Ood off the top of my head I
don't know what more you do with them
so in and of itself
ah
um but
um like if somebody had a pitch that was
interesting Maybe
what I think of watching and dreaming
short version I liked it there's a full
review up in the break room of Geeks
ah
seen in the Ale House finale where the
collector goes for the hug today I saw a
YouTube vid of that titled The Collector
thinks he's Steven Universe
not inaccurate
uh so what do I think of the Jonathan
major situation
ah
dig into it to it too much right now
um yeah Jason as Cameron point out a
review of the break room of Geeks so
here's what I will say
I often
see
um
people who
are trying to call out something about
what's happening to an actor often times
make comparisons that actually don't
make sense to make like when Ezra Miller
first started getting in trouble you
know before
it just kept happening but when Ezra
Miller first started getting in trouble
people were asking like well they fired
Johnny Depp why don't they fire this guy
and like it's not equivocal Johnny Depp
was a supporting part and was a
supporting part in the movie he was
inherently more replaceable
um and the Warner Brothers and you know
the it's the same company but Harry
Potter and DC were not being held by the
same people they're not obligated to
hold themselves to the same standard so
like people like to make comparisons
that aren't Fair here's what I will say
I don't think it is unfair
to ask why Jonathan majors has been
dropped by his representation
when and I went back to try and check so
far as I could find
Ezra Miller wasn't ever dropped by
theirs
so
that does strike me as odd
now as far as the studios involved at
present neither of these actors have
been fired but
it is odd to me that Jonathan majors
is in a situation that Ezra Miller was
in like a year ago
and I don't remember and I could not dig
up any confirmation that Miller was ever
dropped by their representation but
majors has been
that's
that's odd
now do I have an answer as to why not
what I'm comfortable putting any strong
assertions behind but like that is weird
and that is fair to question in some way
you know that Barbra Streisand's
appearance in that coffee talk sketch
was a complete surprise to Myers and the
others I think I did hear that
today's your friend's Jenny's birthday
seems like it's always a birthday of one
of your friends Ms Wicked Wolf
drinking Ramen Coke cause I'm the reason
the rum is gone hey somebody has to be
I and a happy birthday to Jenny as well
well we're here
have I heard about the plans to a Galaxy
Quest TV series I have not and until I
see it actually on a schedule or more
importantly a trailer I'm probably not
going to put too much thought in it lots
of things get pitched lots of things get
pilots and do not move forward
gnome is Wicked Wolf I am not getting
drunk
drunk do you realize you cackle when you
laugh
when I stop and thinking about when I
stop thinking about it I'm aware
I don't
think too much about it though it's just
kind of what happens
uh
let's see
oh a reminder while I do try and keep up
with the chat to the best of my ability
um if you are not on the accounts of
Geeks Discord which is a patreon
exclusive perk the only thing that will
guarantee that I will address your
comment or question uh will be to do it
as a super chat which will also get you
a little heart of appreciation from me
again I will try and keep up with the
chat but I don't make promises outside
of the super chats
um
you know I thought with at least two uh
of your Bad Doctor Who villains
having a monster is uh easier and
cheaper
oh okay I'm not gonna go into the detail
uh of that 255 A.D because that video is
not public yet or is it did it go live
no it did it did go I've got I've got a
video in the pipeline it's not that one
it was another one that one did go live
okay
um so the planet falling apart well I
think you you had a very specific guy
your comments suggests you had a very
specific idea of like a like a from
space shot of the planet Breaking part
like no you shake the camera
and have the doctor like wave the it's
not a screwdriver and go this whole
planet's falling apart that's literally
all you have to do I think you were
overthinking the issue a little bit
can I do a witch cackle I probably could
it would be awkward to try and do on
purpose
especially considering it was cited as
like just kind of how I laugh
I don't know it's one of those things
that like I and I don't have a problem
with maniacal laughs people know that
but I don't know trying to do a witch
cackle on purpose just feels odd
my partner just now discovered she can
braid her hair I love it and I'm so
happy for her Discovery oh that's always
a fun discovery
what do I think James Gunn adapting The
Authority would look like is he actually
adapting it
because he did announce it but like he
announced a slate of things and I'm
pretty sure the only thing he himself is
confirmed to be directly working on is
the new Superman
I
I might be misremembering or I might
have forgotten I don't think he is
personally attached to direct the to
direct the authority
so
I'm not even sure that the that the
premise of the question uh is accurate
what made me want to cut my hair
um
I wanted to I mean I don't know
wait why did I want Thai food for dinner
tonight huh
you do a Shatner tumble
that sounds like a very technical thing
also possibly something that uh
I wouldn't want to put on a resume
did I ever read irredeemable by Mark
Wade
um
possibly it's a question of whether or
not it is what I'm thinking of let me
check that
no no I never did
do you think you'll update versions of
your best and worst MCU villains after
phase six is done maybe
if I feel so inclined
I mean honestly
I've been I I was
phase six would have to kind of reignite
my enthusiasm a bit
phase five
kind of left me kind of meh not left me
cold but left me meh
so I don't know maybe like revisiting
list in general is a thing that might
happen
for most lists that I've already done
which is better tie red curry or Ty
green curry
um I'm actually don't usually go for the
curries I you know I like Pad Thai I
like Pad See you
um
I like stuff like that
um I think I like green curry a little
bit better though by memory it's been a
while since I've had a Thai curry
do I like gorillas I don't know the
gorillas that well outside of the songs
that like everybody knows like Clint
Eastwood and um
oh crap
what the hell is it
oh I can't think of the name of it now
huh
you know the one though it was they was
I think their biggest hit
but uh
yeah
my brain is just completely kicked out
on me never mind reset try again uh Josh
Tyler
digging the hair colors hope you're
doing good I'm doing pretty all right
thank you
I made Thai food this past weekend I've
never tried to cook Thai I like we
actually have a decent Thai place in
town which you wouldn't expect for
Vermont but uh we do started the bad
batch really like the exploration of the
very very early days of the Empire and
the effect on Camino watch reverse
reviews did I ever finish it I never did
I never did go back to it I just
I didn't
it just didn't hold my interest that
much and it was at a point in my life
where and this Remains the case but it
things started to be a case of like
if I'm not pulled towards this I don't
really have time in my schedule for
something that I'm just kind of meh on
and so yeah I never excuse me I never
went back to it
foreign
what's my opinion on Goosebumps they are
a thing that exists
I think I only ever really read one
Goosebump books I was they they they
blew up and got really big
when I was like a year or two too old
for them I think I only ever read
two
of those
I remember I read don't go in the
basement
and another one the name of which I
cannot recall but I didn't stick with
them and like I you know I tried I tried
stuff aimed more at the at the teenage
range you know some of the Fear Street
stuff and things like that and even
those that didn't stick with that much
um but I was dead Goosebumps for me uh
is is a bit like Power Rangers I kind
like I know it was definitely a thing
and I know a little of it
but I was never big into it because I
was like a year or two a little too old
for its for its Target demo
Elder Millennial problems
thank you Peter cunnington for the Super
Chat have you seen
suzumi no
to Jamari your name uh director no I
have not seen that and actually I got uh
your name is is on the Commission list I
actually have a review above it from
some years ago but somebody wanted me to
revisit it so I gotta get to that at
some point have I ever heard of
Creepypasta yes I've heard of it I know
broadly speaking what it is it's again
not really something I ever got into
uh let's see
caving early tonight oh well
rest well then Cara and I hope to see
you on Twitch we should be finishing up
uh super lesbian animal RPG on Twitch
tomorrow
I'm a cool older millennial
that statement implies that there are
uncool older millennials
and I don't think that's true
laughs
oh gosh I'm already I'm ridiculous
favorite Pixar short
the thing is not that many of the shorts
really stuck with me
so I'm having trying to I have to
maybe Jerry's game I did like that one a
fair bit
and the one uh I think was day night the
one that was just the Sun and the Moon
um
rising and setting and like it was all
music and no dialogue I like that one a
bit
um I don't know I did There's I don't I
don't remember all of them that well
what we get a review of Star Trek Picard
season three I will have to watch it
first and I kept meaning to jump
on that because I was hearing real good
things about the third season
and I really should have done it sooner
because unfortunately I've now heard
very mixed things about How It Ends
and that makes me less enthusiastic to
try and catch up on it I still might
no promises I never did get around to
season two so who's my favorite pop
singer oh it's probably still pink
yeah I think I think I can still safely
say that
I'm a zenial born
at the tail end of Gen X honestly
identify more with Millennials late 78.
yeah see like I'm in that
people born in my age range like 80 I
would say 80 to 84.
it's kind of odd because like we're
there for all the stereotypical
Millennial stuff and if for anyone in
that age range who had sand older
sibling they probably are a lot more
aware of the 80s than they should have
been because they would have absorbed it
absorbed pop culture through an older
sibling
um
but then there's you know there's all
the other stuff that's like oh this is
so Millennial and on they loved Pokemon
and Power Rangers and they read
Goosebumps and I'm like those were all
around I was a couple years too old but
like I don't really relate with Gen X
very much just and I don't mean like I
can't relate to Gen X people I just mean
in terms of like cultural touch points
um
I'm like I'm
I'm just a I'm a touch too old
to have like been into like some of the
stuff that I mentioned but I was not old
enough to be all cynical and jaded about
it at the time it was happening so uh
weird nebulous Middle Ground
uh have you watched weathering with you
I don't know what that is and so I'm
gonna say no
uh did you do laser or electrolysis for
your face doing electrolysis down there
to prep for bottom surgery and didn't
think it hurt nearly as much as people
say I had uh laser facial hair removal
um I actually I did a full video uh on
it and that's on the Vera wild Channel
um so that I went into more detail there
um but yeah I I went with laser
um because electrolysis is it's not
exclusively effective on but it is most
effective on light colored hairs
um
whereas laser
it lasers a very quick treatment and it
works well on dark hair which was what I
wanted to deal with because like I
it took me long enough to get around to
it that I was getting gray and white
hairs and the laser doesn't really do
much about that but like I don't worry
about feeling it I'll shave and just not
feel it it was the shadow
it was the Shadow from having the darker
hairs that I really want to dealt with
and laser laser did that for me so
uh let's see oh Supreme
Omega thank you kindly
on 90s DC thoughts on Kyle Raynor I know
he was a legacy hero with a divisive
start because he came in from Emerald
Twilight AKA Hal's turn to villainy I
think a lot of fans didn't give Kyle
Rayner a fair Shake because they were so
mad at how uh Hal was removed from the
um
the monitor of Green Lantern and while
you know Kyle was brought in to kind of
pick up the mantle it's not like they
did that to how in order to introduce
Kyle it's just they needed somebody I
mean what were they gonna do have Guy
Gardner be the main focus hmm no
I haven't read a ton of his stuff I've
like I like what I have seen in terms of
the approach and certainly how he is
distinctly different from not only how
but a whole lot of the lanterns in terms
of
um personality and
um just how he goes about things in his
thought process
that said like they definitely pulled
some like the whole name for the Trope
women's and refrigerators is named after
this after stuff they did with that
character so like he still suffered from
90s bull crap
as far as shorts do you remember La Luna
that's one of my favorite shirts I
remember the name
what it was exactly is not coming to the
Forefront of my mind the recall is not
um working on any trailer reactions
coming up I hope not Jen I'm ready for a
break from Trailer reactions gosh they
just kept coming
ah
season three hasn't ended yet it's an
amazing story you should watch it I mean
I know it hasn't ended yet
the thing is I'm friends with more than
one person
who is getting
um early screening
uh access
to it and I have had it without going
into detail because I asked for no
detail because I might still watch it
but uh I I have had it laid out like by
more than one person that's like new
things things kinda
it kind of took a turn
so but again like I don't know full
context for that I've watched it yet I
might if I get around to it
we'll see I don't know
uh
uh wasn't the one with the hapless alien
who tried to abduct a sleeping dude a
Pixar movie that I think that it was
that one was fun
wait do you still have commissions that
are years outstanding I thought what
happened with exception was kind of an
outlier because you were writing a novel
accession
so here's the thing I have I have a
number of things that are backed up by a
fair amount and the ones that are
uh in terms of commissions are things
that are heavy workload so there's some
written works that are backed up by a
bit there
um I am I am more than halfway through a
season of Television a like a full
season like not of UK like of us network
television like 23 episodes that was
commissioned a while back and I kept
putting it off you know because
when your time is limited it's easier to
um
to check off something that can be done
quicker and when you're working through
something that takes longer you feel
like you're treading water and you're
getting nothing done because or at least
for me there's a part of my brain that's
going you could have gotten four of the
other things that are waiting done in
the time that you're spending trying to
get through this and
that is unfortunately when trying to
work through a backlog an unhelpful
thought process it's part of why
um commissioned video commission review
videos have been a little bit slower
than I would like them to be because I
am trying to hit the oldest stuff in the
backlog right now which right now is a
pile of stuff that is work intensive
um in terms of the amount of time it
will take
um
you know the time dedication on my end
to watch an entire season of TV or read
an entire novel or
um or what have you so that that is uh
that is kind of where things are at I
it started from well look I don't have
time for that but I do have time for
this which was harmless enough but you
do that for too long and suddenly you're
not only backed up but you're backed up
and you've been putting off the longest
stuff
excision was still a little bit of an
outlier insofar as I would have gotten
to it and threw it a lot sooner if I
could have gotten it on an audiobook so
that one was still an outlier as far as
that goes but it's not the only thing
that is only available in written form
that I have to get to and those some of
those have been waiting for a while too
so yeah I I am desperately hoping to get
largely caught up or at least
um get within a more respectable time
frame uh to addressing commissions uh at
some point this year we'll see I hope
you can relate to xaviera
wow you put me with the right gen xer
and I can relate
quite well Carolyn
the 80s I experienced was Smurfs gem
Care Bears He-Man and Shira completely
unaware of politics of the time well
yeah I should hope so if that was your
media diet
uh I'm Jen Zeba my older siblings are
millennials so I grew up with 90s kid
stuff yeah that's kind of what happened
to a lot of
um Millennials in my age range who had
uh Gen X older siblings
opinions on the comic Titans Teen or not
compared to the shows the older I get
the more I find the uh people that never
liked many characters to begin with
whether they enjoyed a show or not I
never really read too much of the Titans
I'm friends with multiple people who
like Titans a lot
um I never really read too much of their
stuff
I keep in mind I didn't read a lot of DC
in general so
let's see
I was like imagining some rolling
Emerick type stuff but if that's what
you meant would that have actually been
cheaper than doing the reaper CG as bad
as it was I mean like the problem with
the Reapers wasn't just The Siege the CG
didn't help it's just conceptually
there's no reason for that to be a
monster and whatever money you put into
designing that stupid monster could have
been reappropriated into you know a
rudimentary effect to be used elsewhere
like
I don't have the I don't have the
accounting of of Father's Day the Doctor
Who episode Father's Day so I don't know
exactly what it costs or exactly what it
would cost to do something different but
fundamentally there's no reason for
those to be monsters for what threat
they represent there's no reason for
them to be monsters
and I will stick by that regardless of
whether or not you think my ideas of
what to do instead are better
let's see
you can react to Ruby Gilman teenage
Kraken
pass loved your moments trailer reaction
that uh that trailer looks fun I'm
really
really hopeful for that
yeah that looked really good
and I think that the cloak and dagger
inverted that because the female
detective found her friend in the
refrigerator I mean yeah I mean it's
it's a brutal thing to do regardless the
whole fridging thing I mean the term
generally is reserved for female
characters who are reduced to being
nothing but a victim in order to
motivate a male character but doing that
to
anybody it's it's
pretty rare that like I'm okay with it
just as a method of moving the story
along because generally there's almost
never a need for to be as brutal as it
is
like you can harm or even just endanger
someone that matters to a character and
motivate them to action you don't have
to brutalize them like that I think it's
very rare that that kind of
brutalization of any character is
um warranted
I just I'm just at a point where a stuff
just seems
cruel
and I'm not into cruelty narrative
cruelty
by and large
even though I can't speak for everyone
here and we can be a bit annoying
sometimes we generally care about you
lots of loves drink water ah thank you
Jamie I appreciate that
uh what were your thoughts on stay out
of the basement I recently watched a
review about how it has a lot of subtext
and metaphor about a father coming out
as gay to his children I mean I read it
in sixth grade so if it did it went over
my head and I can't I can't
I can't respond to that specific claim I
have no idea
it strikes me as the kind of thing that
if I were to guess it's probably
accidental coding
that RL Stein probably create wrote a
situation and create a scenario and did
not realize it mapped onto that
um but it doesn't mean that the coding
isn't valid but accidental coding is a
thing
uh
the only thing that annoyed me with
season three of Picard first they
introduced a character you hate then
he's relatable and then he's spoilers
okay lovely
uh do you still get to watch read uh
play or read uh your own enjoyment
anymore at all
a little
honestly
um
honestly that is something that largely
happens
when I'm taking in a piece of
entertainment with someone else
left completely to my own devices I have
a very very very very hard time
silencing
the uh the voice in my head that says
you should be doing something that is
work you should be you know if I sit
down to watch something
it's very hard to silence the voice that
says that you sh if you're going to
watch something it should be something
you need to watch for work it should be
something that was commissioned it
should be something that you need to
re-watch for reference for this video
You're scripting or whatever so
it's It's Tricky and the main thing that
helps that is to
watch something with somebody else
to
um you know to have someone that you're
enjoying the experience with and that
being able to enjoy that experience of
taking in something with another person
um that is enough that I'm able to shut
that voice up where I can say this is
not work
this is bonding this is
this is friendship this is a
relationship this is you know there's a
romantic partner whatever it may be
to be in that setting I can say I'm not
working right now it's when I'm left
completely on my own that it is hard for
me to justify to myself to not be
working even though I can have a hard
time getting things done you can get uh
with ADHD you can get in this horrible
little paralysis trap of
being rigidly fixed on the things you
should be doing but somehow being unable
to bring yourself to do them and then
you just sit there and get absolutely
nothing productive done whether it was
the thing you should have been doing or
something else and then you just feel
like an absolute crap
so
but yeah that's it that there's an
extended insight into my particular ADHD
but yeah the short version is
um I do watch stuff for enjoyment but it
is for enjoyment with company and often
very very wonderful company so that that
certainly helps
are you more excited for Marvels or
Guardians 3.
I don't know
I I honestly don't know
right yeah I flat out don't know
sketch they should have done at the
Oscars Matt Damon's wife slapsed him and
Kimmel and tells him to keep her
husband's name out of his effing mouth
ah I appreciate the reference
um because I too appreciated the the
Jimmy Kimmel thing the uh
I'm I'm [__] Matt Damon
back and forth thing that went on
um but I don't think turning that
incident from the previous year into a
joke is really in anybody's best
interest especially if it's a joke being
made by people who were not involved in
it
like if the people who were actually
involved in it if they of their own
accord decided they wanted to make a
joke about it I'd at least be like well
if anyone's allowed to it's you I would
say that would be not a great idea
I appreciate the reference
but um
uh let's see
where was I
uh oh here we go
I keep thinking about if I should tell
you to do use of weapons before state of
the art but I always decided against it
because the use of weapons is a loose
sequel oh uh oh yeah first first one
would sort of
meant state of the art yeah like I and
that they're on the docket I will get to
them as soon as I can but
didn't Gale Simone do the Deep dive into
fridging not only did Gail Simone do the
Deep dive into a gale Simone coined the
term her blog was called women in
refrigerators
this was before she was a Comics writer
she was just a blogger Who Loved comics
and hated that nonsense
so yeah women in refrigerators is her
term for codifying that trope
I would skip the Pope's Exorcist I'd
it wasn't really on my radar I thought
it would be John wig meets The Exorcist
but it's just Russell Crowe making goofy
noises and spouting cliche horror lines
for the whole movie I mean that's that's
most horrible horror movies are real
prone to cliche
yeah OSP has a video about how bad
fridging is multiple people have tackled
the topic but yeah OSP did a good one
uh speaking of needing to be rescued I
saw a review of the uh uh of the pirate
movies pointing out that Jack is the one
always needing to be rescued yeah
which yeah
let's see
love the new hair have I read Ready
Player one no I have no interest in
Reading Ready Player one I saw the movie
it was okay
um and I know the book is somewhat
different but no I never I never did
read that
fun fact about RL Stein he worked on
Eureka's Castle before he got into kid
Horror oh
I think I might have heard that but I I
had forgotten yeah he's had an odd
career
prior to like solidifying himself as a
as a horror horror writer for minors I
have to be sure I articulate that well
because horror is one of those words
that like if you don't
if you Mumble your way through that you
end up with just [__] and uh whoops
uh
yeah the person who reviewed the book
and said that was gay tub subtext was
clearly thought it was accidental I just
want to know if you got something
similar as a queer child oh I would oh I
I did not have proper clear
lenses on in sixth grade
like even by then I didn't think I was
straight but like I wasn't viewing the
world through properly queer lenses I
didn't have enough sense of myself to be
doing that so
and that's even getting aside from the
fact that
memories fade after
jeez almost 30 years
ah
process and work ethic is a [__]
yeah oh well thank you for stopping into
alt Trekkie
uh
uh so far behind on pop arena I don't
think I'm actually familiar with
paparina's work I'm not sure I've seen
any of those videos
oh hey Meg I didn't see you come in good
to see you
uh
the Oscars are rigged no they're no
they're not rigged they're subject to a
lot of BS internal politics but no
they're uh they're not rigged that's
that's
flatly false so now
I'm trying to chill today it's not easy
for me oh Meg Big relate
any thoughts on the Star Wars
celebration news of a Mando versus movie
a new Ray movie a movie about the first
Jedi Mana is probably what I was most uh
I want most but excited for Rey uh yeah
I never did get around to talking about
that the reason I never got around to
talking about those announcements is
because my reaction to pretty much all
of them is
the okay
like what I have by far the least
interested in is a story about the first
Jedi like I I
I'm so done with the Jedi and I really
don't care
Rey could have potential I need to know
what they're gonna do story wise because
she unfortunately was involved in a
Trilogy that knows dive not her fault
but like I would like to see the
character treated better but until I see
a trailer or at least hear a concept I
don't know for certain that that's
what's gonna happen and I I bailed on
the Mandalorian
some years ago so I really don't care
about that
and that's that's the thing that's why I
didn't do a reaction because it's not
even like I'm not mad I'm not saying
these are bad ideas or they shouldn't be
done it's just me and for where I'm at
with Star Wars right now and what things
um General are more appealing to me as a
fan of Star Wars I see that line up and
go
no okay
Thomas Ahern thank you very very much
would a franchise like Doctor Who still
exists if we were to get rid of
capitalism
sorry I'm trying
I don't
know how to even begin parsing that
question
like
would any of our entertainment exist or
at least exist in the form that it does
without if we got if we quote unquote
got rid of capitalism like I don't
understand the logic of your question
I don't
yeah no I I don't
I don't understand the through line of
the question
um
at all
I guess
if I were to guess at what you're
getting at is because the show is
broadly speaking fairly Progressive and
always has been to varying degrees
would it exist in the form that it does
if it didn't have capitalism to comment
upon to which the obvious answer is well
no it's a product of the environment in
which it was made as is literally all
art which is part of why I also can't
parse this question because you're
basically asking me
if the world was literally completely
different from how it is would this
piece of art still exist and
I
short answer is no but it's going to be
no regardless of what you ask because
every piece of art is a product of the
environment it's made in
so like that's just an across the board
answer
and so I feel like you must have been
asking something more specific but I I I
I can't parse that I don't
I
mean part of this might just be how my
brain does or doesn't work but I can't
wrap my head around that question
not a horror movie fan I am a picky
horror movie fan
I'm on the waiting list to get tested
for ADHD it's currently five years wait
yeah I
yeah sounds about right
did I ever see Winnie the Pooh Blood and
Honey oh did that actually come out
I didn't know if that was out yet yeah
uh so no no I haven't
uh let's see I answer the Final Jeopardy
question correct last night so I'm
feeling like a rock star yeah
that's always a good feeling
I love the book so much honestly oh so
this is ready player one all the 80s
references and the way it's written
absolutely grabbed me the movie's
actually terrible compared to the book
see the thing is I don't really care
about references
I mean I don't
and the reason I was never that
interested in the book is because it
seemed like pop culture specific age
range of Pop Culture references the
novel and like
I don't care
and that's not to diminish anyone who
did like it but like I don't I
I'm sorry I don't
excuse me
uh new here's amazing oh thank you
Eternal sailor I appreciate that
uh I was just wondering if in literature
or media is it okay for a character to
transition uh if there was no clear hint
or indicator of them going in that
direction from the start short answer
yes
um I kind of addressed this
years ago in a video that I don't know
how well it holds up but I kind of
addressed this some years ago and my
overall opinion has not changed that it
is there is nothing inherently
invalid
about having a character come out as
trans or gay or non-binary or whatever
when there had been no previous hints
because you know what for a lot of
people
from the outside looking in when you're
not privy to the inner thoughts and
inner turmoils and everything going on
inside another person's head that's how
it can look like from the outside
you know somebody comes out as as trans
or gay or whatever and there will be
some people in some circumstances go
there was never a hint now the cliche is
yeah we already knew we were waiting for
you to tell us and that certainly
happens a lot but it can go the other
way too
and that's not an invalid story to try
and tell now there are still better and
worse ways to handle that like with
literally any story but is it okay as a
general thing to do yes yes it is
I just want to see Ray train Finn that's
all I need
well then I hope you get it I still am
very indifferent
paparina's on the verge of 1991 in the
retrospective of knickknacks and is
presently doing commissioned episode
reviews huh I have to see what they do
and see if it's something I want to sink
time into
good Pirates of the Caribbean work as a
TV series
maybe a more serialized one it wouldn't
work episodic it would get too
repetitive
um
serialized possibly like with a
overarching story per season Maybe
I saw Shazam 2 yesterday whilst not
whilst what a great move what a great
word whilst not a good movie jaimon Hans
who understood the assignment well
that's good
I'm happy for you to get either of them
whenever but what is uh actually easy
for you to get through a written short
story or full length and audiobook form
I mean easier is the audiobook I have
gotten my hands on the short story
though so I
I'll I'll address them in whatever makes
the most sense
and we'll we'll move forward on that
basis
do I listen to David Bowie much not a
ton from being honest I like Bowie but I
never like got deep into him uh
especially
Papa rina's main project is documenting
early Nickelodeon show by show if you
have any Nostalgia for pre-90s Nick you
should check him out oh
all right
so Supremo Mega
also on 90s Comics do I remember wizard
Matt yes I remember wizard magazine
I might still have some issues with that
kicking around in the Attic somewhere I
was reluctant to get rid of old
magazines
oh goodness
that's my favorite Scream movie well I
haven't seen all of them and it's the
first one regardless Discord yes thank
you carowind for that reminder
um all right
so let's see here at 255 A.D you don't
have to worry about alerting me Carolyn
was on top of it she always is so you
don't have to pick up that baton It is
Well carried so I'm going to pop over to
the Council of Geeks Discord reminder
that is a patreon exclusive perk which
is the other way aside from Super chats
that you can ask me questions that I
will definitely address on stream I will
go through these as quickly as I am able
and I will be back in the chat in a few
minutes
have you had the chance to watch Contra
points's latest video on The Witch
Trials of JK Rowling I did I have like
minor nitpicks on a couple of points but
by and large I certainly agree with her
overall messages statements and the
comparison she made in terms of who she
compared and paralleled uh rolling and
other gender critical people with was
well thought out and well
um laid out it was good
uh would you what what do what would you
consider the worst superpower to have
just being Radioactive
like not being able to channel radiation
but just like constantly emitting
radiation
so everything around you is gonna die
yeah I'd say that would be it uh if you
had a cocktail named after you what
would the ingredients be oh
oh okay
um
I kind of wanna
I wanna try a modified Paloma with some
of the local Maple rum see how that
works it might work
or it might be a disaster I'd have to
try it and I would
what are some of the nicest comments
you've had on your videos
nicest I mean there's there's just
generally there's a lot of stuff saying
you know I like your outfit I like your
lipstick those are those are nice I mean
the ones that
um I enjoy getting our somebody saying
anything to the effect of
um you know I felt like you expressed
what I was feeling or thinking but you
said it better than I could or someone
that's like wow I never thought of it
that way I like I like ones that sort of
the ones that land with me the the best
are the ones that tend to fall along the
lines of feeling like somebody really
connected with something I did and
people will will word that in different
ways
uh let's see remember I point out to you
that the ghost of Molly McGee is one of
the few shows where the two main
characters are child siblings and
they're not written to hate each other
why do you think that is like why is it
the convention of fictional siblings to
low-key hate each other and argue
constantly I don't know as an only child
I legitimately don't know my primary
guess would be that there's just been
it's just been way too normalized that
that's how siblings treat each other
especially
um siblings of not the same gender it
seems to be taken as a given that they
hate each other or at least argue
constantly and I don't know why I have
no idea why
only child I don't get it
um
remember I told you a lefty streamer I
follow is a teacher and someone falsely
told her school she's a groomer ideally
how do you think school admins should
respond to accusations like that I mean
I want to say if a queer teacher or in
this case an outspoken Ally gets accused
of being inappropriate with kids the
school should just default assume it's
fake but if you work with kids your
bosses even looking into something like
this can put a stand on your reputation
and future career prospects
I do not have any kind of comprehensive
or definitive answer to that the broad
Strokes that I would say is that it is
worth taking into consideration the
source
now this is not to completely disregard
um
you know it's say an anonymous report
but you investigate all of it but I
would say that you move a lot quicker
and a lot more decisively when a student
comes to you with something then a
random email that you can't trace and
again that's not to ignore it you look
into it because it's too risky not to
but
and this is this is why blanket policies
of like and we always treat it the same
way are bad
because you treat everything equally and
then somebody with a [__] claim will
have their their claim treated with just
as much severity as somebody in genuine
danger and that's not helpful but the
specifics of how to do that and avoid
the pitfalls I don't know I'm not a
school administrator don't ask me
throughout the culture series there's
multiple assigned female birth
characters who transition to men for a
while and it's presented as a perfectly
reasonable choice and worthwhile
experience by contrast to only one major
assigned male birth character Gunnar
hafon becomes a woman and it's presented
as a mistake do you think banks might be
displaying
a touch accidental misogyny uh in that
like I'm reminded part of your tomboy
video where you pointed out a girl
wanting to be masculine can be seen as
aspirational where a boy wanting to be
feminine is more seen as shameful yeah
and like I'm sure I wasn't conscious on
his part that's probably not something
he ever stopped to think about but yes
that is the exact kind of thing that I
think
um unexamined or unrealized
inherent misogyny and not like you're a
misogynist but like cultural misogyny
and when you're raised in that culture
when you're raised in a patriarchal
culture with a lot of inbuilt misogyny
you absorb it and if you are not going
out of your way to be consciously aware
of it yeah it seeps in in ways like that
so yeah I would say that's a probably an
accurate diagnosis that
if pressed he would have said I didn't
mean to do that and I don't know enough
about the guy maybe he would have gone
oh dang oh I did make a mistake but I I
seriously doubt based off what I have
read that it would have been done on
purpose I don't think that would have
been the case but
that's the thing about uh unconscious
biases
you're not conscious of them
like that's that's why sensitivity
readers freaking matter I don't care
what you wrote
uh jumping off your take on sick Transit
Veer on jump gate so this is the today's
episode no not today yesterday's episode
of The Jump game podcast about Babylon
5. can you
excuse me can you think of any other
example of watching an otherwise good
series and thinking that a decent writer
simply seems to have forgotten how to
structure an episode or write not sure
hell-bent counts
um
probably
Transit via is a real is a bit of an
outlier because it's it's the kind of
mess of an episode that you would assume
is being written by a guest writer who
who didn't really know everything
properly but like most of these episodes
are written by JMS
so yeah I don't know what happened I
could probably think of some other
examples somewhere well I I suppose
actually
um
probably even a better example than hell
band if we're going with Doctor Who is
love and monsters like
Russell T Davis can be a really
insightful writer and he's working with
the broadest Strokes in that and it the
approach feels like dude what what are
you doing and I do think some of the
underlying ideas could have worked but
like whereas hell hellbent is just such
a mess and it feels like such a uniquely
Moffat mess that as much as I hate it
and I hate it I still have an odd kind
of respect for it I'm like
you followed your own weird Muse down
this rabbit hole but that rabbit holds a
bottomless pit and I'm not coming down
after you but I kind of respect you for
jumping down there I guess
um
we have had uh the founder about
McDonald's Tetris air what should be the
next movie on licensing ipb and what is
it with this trend what is it with the
trend is that Hollywood loves to find a
way to
valorize the people behind the scenes
it's the same reason they made Moneyball
I mean who the hell wants a baseball
movie
about people running math algorithms to
figure out who they should be scouting
I'll tell you who
people who run Studios
and don't and feel like they don't get
the proper credit
like there's there's an appeal for
Studios especially if they can turn it
into what they think is a Prestige
affair
to like go and look at all this behind
the scenes stuff that happens in these
creative Fields isn't it cool isn't the
kind of thing I do as a producer really
cool no dude it's not sign the check and
let an actual creative person do
something that's a that's harsh like
that implies that there's no creativity
in these projects there probably is but
there's a reason that things like that
get funding
whereas some other stuff doesn't
who put the ram in the rama lama ding
dong I don't know one of the true
philosophical quandries of our age
as a European could you attempt to
explain to me why America is one of the
only developed countries yet to abolish
the death penalty
uh you would have uh you would have
though with so many Christian considers
claiming to be pro-life that I you would
have thought with so many Christian
consumers claiming to be pro-life that
would be the first thing they want to
abolish well the first thing to be clear
about pro-life is not actually pro-life
pro-life is
um anti-women's Freedom the pro-life
movement is not about preserving or
saving lives because most people who are
pro-life are also Pro death pro-death
penalties statistically speaking they
don't actually care if people ever die
they care about breeding rates and they
care about women having options other
than stay home and raise a child and
they don't want and if a woman has been
made pregnant and is trapped to
potentially be stuck to stay at home and
raise a child they don't want her to be
able to escape from that
so that's the first thing so pro-life
pro-life was very sneakily named they're
not pro-life George Carlin himself said
it they're not uh they're not pro-life
they're anti-woman
um but as far as the death penalty there
is
there is just a I mean the thing is
first of all realize that it varies from
state to state as almost everything does
in this country
um there is death penalty for some
federal cases but by and large you are
dealing with state by state and some
states do not have the death penalty
some do some states that have the death
penalty are very careful about how they
apply it some are Texas
so it really is all over the place and
so it comes down to a fairly localized
mentality especially of whoever happens
to be in charge but by and large
conservatives love the death penalty
um
because it's the harshest form of
control they can grant and I don't like
to do these broad sweeping
generalizations if I can help it but by
and large
conservative movements and conservative
parties
really love anything that gives them as
much control over other people as
possible now they will claim that they
are the government of they they are in
favor of small government and less
government control and it's all lies
it's all lies they don't want they want
people to have fewer options while
claiming that they want more freedoms
it's all [__] but
the authority and the ability to end
someone's life is the ultimate form of
control over another person
so
yeah there you go
probably pissed off somebody with the
way I chose to frame that but
why do you think we don't get
long-running sci-fi shows like we used
to all the modern popular sci-fi shows I
can think of are either reboots of old
ones have a limited Runner got canceled
after two or three seasons
well you need to remember there weren't
that many long-running TV shows this is
one of the things we have to be careful
about when we think back to our own
Nostalgia is there is a strong
um survivor's bias which is that we
remember the stuff that has been best
preserved but there's tons of stuff
that did not last long that was
short-lived that was quickly forgotten
now there's also like you know we think
long running you think Star Trek the
first series of Star Trek only had three
seasons
like don't forget that and even other
stuff
if you truly broke it down into Seasons
only had like three maybe four but then
got syndicated into Oblivion and reruns
and so it felt like it was on forever
help original Star Trek series did that
so I'm not sure I agree with the framing
of the question
I mean in general at this point there
aren't that many Super long-running
Series other than reality shows broadly
speaking anyway because that's they we
are apparently on the tail end of the
quote-unquote golden age of Television
where we had [__] like Breaking Bad and
Game of Thrones and whatnot but now that
stuff is no longer seen as being as
economically viable to throw as much of
that at the wall and a lot more stuff
gets cut short either deliberately or
um you know either by Design or by
cancellation but
always keep in mind that we it's easy to
think about boy this thing ran forever
and that thing ran forever yeah and
there were 15 other things that you
don't even remember or maybe never even
knew existed that didn't last for crap
so you have to be careful about the the
bias towards
um what is remembered
uh why do you think Disney is green
lighting the ray Star Wars trilogy but
canceling Ryan Johnson's Trilogy did
they officially cancel that or did they
not just announce or did they not just
give any more word on it I didn't catch
it being officially canceled if I were
to guess it's because Ryan Johnson
probably has moved on because he seems
way more interested in doing
um
more
um knives out stuff right now
it looks like me like pandering to the
loudest most obnoxious fans which is a
shame because most of the critics and
Casual fans like The Last Jedi and some
characters in that film got more
development than Ray did across the
entire Trilogy I don't I don't think
pandering makes sense because the people
who were the biggest complainers also
hated Rey so it's not like doing a ray
Trilogy is going to as opposed to Ryan
Johnson's proposed Trilogy whatever that
was it's not like that's going to make
that same crowd any happier because most
of them hate Rey too so pandering no I
think it is a calculated move based off
availability of talent and trying to
figure basically trying to figure out
what's worth throwing at the wall to see
if it sticks
who put the bump in the bombshell bomb
as that uh is we doing the whole song
now what are we doing who was the masked
Avenger
who was that masked man
uh what are the odds Marvel drops Majors
as kings and go as Kang goes with a
different actor now that he appears to
be an actor jail of the announcement of
his uh repping firm no longer
representing him well uh hold on
sorry I had to clear my throat
um I don't know I'm not one to give odds
but like I'm
I am surprised that his representation
dropped him without Disney having
already dropped him I would have thought
that if his representation was going to
drop him it would have been at the same
time not in advance of uh assuming
Disney and Marvel even do drop him I
think right now they're still in a
paralyzed situation where
they want to know to a higher degree of
certainty if this is going to go to
court or not if it is they will cut ties
but for a while it feels more up in the
air I think they're really scared I
think they're really scared to make a
move
um just PR wise and because like people
when I did my video on that initially
people got hung up in the logistics and
then everyone like oh well like you can
just say it's a Multiverse he looks
different you can recast I'm not saying
you can't recast I'm saying they're wary
of the pr issue especially because of
the last time they moved too quickly on
something and that was James Gunn and it
cost them a lot and not just egg on
their face but it cost them a lot a lot
of time and a lot of lost momentum
um you know with what happened with
Guardians of the Galaxy part 3 and they
are going to be wary about moving too
fast and at the same time though it's a
question of well how long do you wait
before doing anything because right now
right now
in the choice between fight or flight
they are Frozen at the moment
all right I'm back I'm back
uh I am just gonna come down to the
um
to the to the bottom of the chat because
like I I was I was on that for a while
so
I need some counsel a distant relative
share to post that was transphobic I
want to give her benefit of the doubt
and assume she just doesn't understand
how do I rebuke her ideally
um privately
uh
I would recommend
like I can't give you advice on what
specific thing to say
um I I can't give you that advice at all
because it's going to have to be
tailored to who they are as a person and
the nature of your relationship and I
don't know that and I can't write you a
script
but
what I can tell you is you're probably
much better off reaching out directly
and privately than trying to bring it up
publicly because they are most anybody's
more likely to get defensive if they
feel called out in public so that is
advice that I would give as far as the
best way to approach
it it should be tailored and
personalized which means I'm not in a
position to really give solid advice
there
oh vosh isn't happy about Contra points
to the video I'm sure he's not
[__] them
I genuinely love the culture and shape
my ideological development at the same
time I'm willing to make observations
like that is that weird like I love it
but I can be critical no
I think the best criticism usually comes
from people who love a thing loving a
thing does not mean thinking it's
perfect
I love Doctor Who it's not freaking
I love my own written works some of them
they're not perfect any of them
like
it's not it does not diminish Your Love
of a piece of work to recognize that
there are flaws in either the work
itself or the people who made it
uh
see
what is your history with classic
animation shorts Mickey Mouse Silly
Symphonies Looney Tunes Etc I have the
most familiarity with old Disney shorts
because my
um my grandmother had the Disney Channel
when I was when I was little and this
was back when the Disney Channel was a
premium cable channel and didn't have
ads and they used to do blocks of you
know the old cartoons often blocked out
by characters there'd be like a block of
Mickey Mouse a block of goofy a block of
Donald and she would uh she'd tape a lot
of that off the TV and send me those so
that I could watch them at home
so I have the most familiarity with
Mickey Mouse I have a decent amount with
Looney Tunes
um Tom and Jerry uh and Max Fleischer I
only ever caught bits and pieces of here
and there
um
but like I kind of grew up with the
Disney stuff the most
but also caught a fair amount of Warner
Brothers
um just because it was usually I was
just kind of floating around
is vosh ever happy
I don't pay attention to him so
uh
thank you for the Super Chat 255.50 A.D
get to my commissions in your in your
own time thank you for that
honestly I barely know her that well
she's married to a cousin from another
country ah
what do I have against vosh
I probably shouldn't answer that
all right [__] it short version I have
two problems with vosh one is just with
the entire type of content that he makes
and so it's not unique to him I have an
issue with debate Bros in general I find
the format of what they do and the way
that they approach doing it to be
generally unhelpful and seems to be a
lot more about dunking on people than
actually pushing forward and getting a
better understanding of helpful and
useful ideas
they seem way more interested in just
dunking on the other side and making the
other side look like idiots which I'm
not saying has no use whatsoever but
it's one of those things that like that
shouldn't be the only thing you do that
shouldn't be your entire Praxis and so
people who base their entire thing on
just
you know trying to own the other side
I don't really have time for that I
don't really care what their political
perspective is and the other thing is
basically what Contra points brought up
in the video I do not believe it is okay
to wield tools of misogyny or
transphobia or anything of that nature
against someone I don't like so the
thing that Contra points cited was that
vosh was flatly misogynistic to JK
Rowling and it's not okay because being
misogynistic is a toxic and harmful
thing no matter who it's directed at and
there is plenty to criticize about JK
Rowling without ever having to be a
misogynistic towards her there is no
need for that it belittles into bases
genuine criticism because people are
going to conflate actual critique of the
things she's saying with you just being
a misogynistic [__] at her even if
you think that it's Justified because
you dislike her that much it's not this
is not vastly dissimilar to what I said
what I've said in the past about of
respecting the pronouns of Ezra Miller
and people have tried to argue with me
because when you do that you signal that
it is appropriate to do that for other
people and respecting someone is such a
is such a biased and inherent and uh
deeply personal measure that once you
open the door for I don't have I don't
have to not be misogynistic to a woman
if I don't respect her or I don't have
to I don't have to do someone's proper
pronouns if I don't respect them that
just says that anyone can set their own
measure and it says that there are
circumstances in which it is okay to be
openly misogynistic to a woman for the
purposes of harassing her or to
misgender a person because you don't
respect them there are plenty of things
wrong with Ezra Miller with JK Rowling
with freaking anyone but doing these
things to fundamentally dehumanize them
is not only unhelpful and cruel It
undermines Whatever point you think it
is that you're trying to make
so
there you go
uh you ever watched UPA forgot to have
that in the last comment I don't know
what UPA is so I'm going to assume
not
uh
uh have you seen an ambulance the action
movie I have not and I am going to wrap
it up I'm gonna wrap it up I've finished
my water
I've gone on I've gone on a rant
where uh
we're gonna finish it off there so
um oh what's coming up let me think so
um first thing is
um I will be on stream on Twitch
tomorrow probably finishing uh my
playthrough of
um
super lesbian animal RPG
um so that that should be fun
um
UPF was an animation studio I'll tell
you about it oh thank you Carolyn I look
forward to learning
um
so uh let's see where
what else so like there's that
um Saturday is a new video on the main
Channel
um this what is this one oh
I'm gonna be briefly touching on the
idea of
um JK Rowling giving up the uh
intellectual property rights to Harry
Potter which is something that a lot of
people in my comments seem to have been
wishing for and I have thoughts about
having that as a desire and whether or
not
um a whether or not it would ever happen
or B whether or not it is even helpful
to hope for that that'll be Saturday's
video
um
I think I might have a
uh the I think I might have something in
the break room
then my bra like I'm
I think I think the hair dye went to my
brain I'm like I'm having a hard time
kick-starting it I think that's
everything that's coming up in the
immediate
anyways
uh thank you for
um your time
your patience
your company
thank you all and I hope that you have a
wonderful rest of the week
and I want you to remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
mckevity